So here's the code, that we had at the end of unit two. Our goal
now is to modify that code, instead of printing all links, to get all links.
The good news is, the get_next_target we don't have to change
at all. We still want to find the next URL in the
page. We're going to need to make a few changes to print
all links to make get all links. But not too many.
The first change we need to make is we need to
introduce a variable to keep track of the results. So I'll
call that variable links. I'll leave it as a quiz for
you to figure out what the initial value of links should be.
Remember, our goal for get_all_links is that
at the end of get_all_links, it will
return a list containing all of the links that we found on this page.